he needs to know the truth let's truth
about wall about himself
no one knows no one but me hey everybody
we finally got that movie size finale so
there's so much stuff to pick through
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet there is a new
round of that HBO now giveaway happening
- all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
so r.i.p the wall there was this really
awesome shot when it was snowing in
King's Landing as Jamie was leaving you
go from the really big wide shot which
looks really beautiful you could tell
they definitely spent a ton of extra
money to show King's Landing in its full
glory they could have searched these
floor map and you see snow falling all
over it and it's a great visual metaphor
for what's coming winter is coming for
all of Westeros but I'll say right off
the bat this is probably one of the best
episodes of the season if not the best
just because of all the character
moments so some of the characters had
their best scenes of the season in this
episode particularly Tyrion who's been a
bit of a problem this season so let's
just go through top 10 WTF this is gonna
be a little bit longer because the
episode was longer but starting with
number 10
Jon's group rolls up to the dragon pit
you get a little bit of a history lesson
and you start getting those really
awesome reunions
Podrick and Tyrion Brienne in the Hound
that was so great you see how much the
Hound has turned around as a character
when he chuckles and implies that he's
not gonna try and get in Brienne's way
as if he wouldn't have a chance against
her so it's a really nice way to show
how all these different groups have put
aside their differences in common cause
for the army of the Dead but the even
more beautiful thing about the dragon
pit later is crazy a place as it is I've
done a couple history videos about it
about how maegor the cruel is the one
that created it when he blew up the
great set of the time the way the Cersei
is blown up the great Sept and you get
that Daenerys speech about how she feels
like it was the beginning of the end for
their family you try to chain up this
wonderful thing and control it and we've
actually heard on the show before about
how the Dragons would grow smaller and
smaller and smaller the skull that Jon
Snow picks up is the one that's supposed
to be as big as a dog that's one of the
book quotes where they literally say the
last dragons that were alive were no
bigger than hounds because it was the
finale most of this was all in service
of paying stuff off but there was a lot
of foreshadowing for next season so I'll
try to work that in as I work through
this list here but the dragon pit was
great I loved how awful you're on as
being even Cersei speaks up for Tyrion
although I think mostly to keep things
moving along
there was so much
a family in the episode that at first
second I was like maybe Cersei is
standing up for Tyrion because he's
family but I think in her case it was
just to move things along more but
number nine speaking of family the hound
lets the mountain know how it's going to
end for him you've always known so I
feel like this is them telling us that
they're gonna do Clegane Bowl before
season 8 is done so the hound
wants clicking Bowl just as badly as you
do but there's all kinds of questions
about how is the mountain gonna get up
north is the Hound gonna come back to
King's Landing after they fight the army
of the Dead because I don't see the next
time they're gonna be in a room together
unless they come back or Cersei comes up
to the north I was a little surprised
that Cersei didn't make any jokes about
Daenerys rolling up with two dragons
instead of three dragons but I think
that was to make you know number eight
revealing the white to everyone hit a
little bit more so she does finally
react to something like holy crap like
she actually believes it in that moment
whether she believed it or not before
she's always one of those masters of not
betraying her emotion so when she does
get really emotional you know [ __ ] is on
it was a bit of a comedy reveal - as the
Hound sort of tiptoeing around the box
everything's dead silent you're just
waiting for the jump-scare so he kicks
it over it comes out and as he hacks it
to pieces
Qyburn picks up that hand I love the
look on his face he's not scared at all
he's just completely fascinated by it
because he's fascinated in the secrets
of death that's the whole reason why he
was kicked out of the Citadel he opened
the bodies of the living to learn about
death as opposed to the opposite where
you opened the bodies of the dead to
learn about life so if there's anybody
in King's Landing that is excited about
the army of the Dead right now
it is Qyburn like holy crap I can learn
so much from this maybe you'll have some
sort of solution to help out Samwell but
Samwell is really the one with all the
information from the Citadel they've
already explained what Euron's up to how
he's going to get the golden company and
bring them back I was surprised by how
quickly they paid off that you're on
story line I would have thought they
would have saved that for season eight
some big reveal like oh you thought that
we went back to Pyke nope we came back
with 20,000 soldiers horses and
elephants just think of what those would
look like in the army of the Dead but
they hit a couple nice beats with the
characters even Brienne and Jaime get a
brief moment which is probably the whole
reason why they won
in King's Landing so they could have
that Jamie moment where she says [ __ ]
loyalty they raked John over the coals
about his loyalty this is gonna get you
killed
Ned Stark was an honorable person look
what happened to him and I think that's
more to provide a counterpoint for
Cersei in the episode you know so number
seven the Cersei tyrion scene
fantastic probably Tyrians best scene
this season is almost like they were
saving all the good stuff for Tyrion for
this moment when he was with Cersei and
they just unload on each other but you
actually learned that Cersei understands
that he didn't kill Joffrey but still
blames him for Marcella and Tommen and
she traces it all back to his killing of
Tywin but you know then he also throws
their mother in their face I killed our
mother you can blame me for that too
there seems better than Jaime and Cersei
seen at the end of the episode even
though that was a bigger payoff like
Jaime is finally leaving Cersei
but number six Littlefinger in sauces
last big scene together where he starts
to imply that Arya wants to kill her
she's worried about what Jon Snow's
doing and this alliance with Daenerys
and you have this sort of work this
moment in Reverse from what ends up
happening to Littlefinger later when he
gets killed by arya like at what point
did Sansa learned about what he did in
King's Landing because we didn't see
that conversation with Brant so what I
think the idea is is that as of last
week's episode when Arya is still going
at it with Sansa they're still being
genuine in that moment but Arya has
already had that conversation with Sansa
earlier in the episode where she
basically tells her that's not me I
don't want to be the lady of a castle
like you did so I think that
Littlefinger's critical mistake is when
he suggests that Arya wants to be the
lady of Winterfell in Sansa had just
gotten done going back and forth with
Arya about how she didn't want any of
that so it's a little hard to read
sophie Turner's face here but you see
her paws a little bit I'm guessing that
after this happened then she went to
talk to Aria and bran
then they learned about all the stuff
that happened in King's Landing him
betraying Ned Stark him being
responsible for Jon Arryn precipitating
everything that led to the war of the
five kings although he wasn't completely
responsible he was definitely behind
most of it but there had to have been a
scene where Brant explained all that to
them because Sansa only knew about a
little bit of it she knew about
Littlefinger killing Lysa but all the
stuff back during season one the King's
Landing Ned Stark stuff
she and
Aria wouldn't have known about any of
that unless brand told them and I'm
assuming that because brand was sitting
in the room during the scene they had
just gotten done talking to him but
number 5 that amazing Theon seen with
John where it's basically like a version
of Brienne and Jaime where John's good
qualities have started to rub off on
Theon and now he's inspired to go rescue
his sister but he's at war within
himself and Ja gives in the big speech
about how you don't have to pick one or
the other stark or Greyjoy you don't
have to betray one to honor the other he
has that great fight club scene where he
takes down the person who fished him out
of the water
he's the stepping stone that Theon needs
to inspire the others and it's really
that small band there to go to save Yara
so that's gonna be a big season 8 thing
the other important thing in that John
conversation too is is sort of the hat
tip for Targaryen stuff happening in the
future like how is John so gonna deal
with the reveal that he's half Targaryen
and it sounds like incest Bom aside
he'll actually be able to deal with it
relatively well because that's basically
what he tells the Theon is that you
don't have to pick one family or the
other so we got a big battle between
your on and Theon happening in Season
eight but number four Arya executes
Littlefinger so it's such a big
character death but I'm just so happy
that they're moving past this garbage
Sansa Arya storyline like I said earlier
in the video there's a certain point at
which they figured out what Littlefinger
was doing after a brand explained all of
his treachery so I feel like that all
happened off screen and we weren't meant
to see it just so we could get this
surprise here whether or not you were
surprised I mean I really felt like
Littlefinger was gonna die this season
so when she turned her head and little
fingers like what are you talking about
I have no idea about this treachery you
speak of there was a moment of surprise
on my face but I was like okay this is
how it happens this is the moment but
honestly they've kind of been dumping on
the Littlefinger character for the last
couple of seasons in favor of sonses
storyline and her development and there
was a lot of stuff that got shoehorned
into this false conflict between her and
Arya that I'm just glad that the
storyline is over and we don't have to
deal with it again so it was a big
moment I love how Arya executed him but
I'm not happy in the way the writers got
there even though we were headed in this
direction eventually but number three
Samwell rolls up with Gilly and we
learned that he actually paid attention
when she was talking about the maester
who recorded all of his craps
so you brush through it really quickly I
was surprised by how quickly they rolled
into that Blache back you get the
Rhaegar Leon a marriage and I actually
laughed a little bit when bran was like
his name is actually sand because
bastards in Dorne our names sand and I
almost wanted to shout out no he'd
actually be a waters because he was born
two at our gear and his father would
have had naming rights it's not just
where you're born it's actually who
you're born to but you can argue about
what his true bastard name would be
because they revealed that his real name
is Aegon Targaryen so there's a really
cool reveal really happened they finally
paid that off but it also raises some
interesting questions too because
there's the fake Aegon of the books and
if George R Martin explained that John's
true name is Aegon then it's only more
confirmation that fake Aegon is actually
a Blackfyre not a true Targaryen
but because fake Aegon is pretending to
be the baby of Rhaegar and Elia Martell
it reminds you that Rhaegar already had
a son with Elia named Aegon so why then
is Rhaegar obsessed with having a new
baby the fulfillment of the prophecy in
naming it Aegon again did he just change
the name of his last baby like he just
has a bunch of babies named Aegon now so
you guys can let me know do you think
that his name will also be Aegon in the
books because even though they changed
minor things and bump up characters
storylines big reveals like that like R
plus L equals J feels like it would have
to be relatively true to the book reveal
but bran is amazingly lucid in this
scene and I love when Samwell rolls up
and he explains how he's the three-eyed
Raven and he gives him the same look
that Sansa gave him I don't know what
that means that's like the default
reaction to three-eyed raven I have
absolutely no idea what that means but
as they make the big reveal about the
marriage his true name you get to both
sexes
and as you know fun as this big payoff
is like okay this incest bomb is gonna
blow up in season eight it's gonna be so
fun to see what they do with it
you see Tyrians face off in the hallway
looking very concerned like ooh this
might not end well like he's not excited
for them he actually looks worried like
this might end badly but if you remember
earlier in the episode they actually
tipped the hat to future Daenerys baby
possibilities because as she's
explaining the end of the Targaryen
family in the dragon pit she reminds us
like she literally says I will never
have more children
I actually just posted a video about the
me remaster prophecy she shouts her out
to the woman who murdered my child and
my husband told me that I would never
have children again so we'll add a link
for that at the end of this but it's all
just clues pointing to the possibility
that Daenerys could become praying it at
some point in season 8 and I don't know
that we'd ever see the baby be born on
the show because there's not that much
time but we'll see I'll talk more about
that on my season 8 predictions video
and then of course number one big night
King reveal army of the Dead bringing
the wall down
r.i.p the wall pretty much the only big
action set piece in the episode but we
knew it would have to happen to Benchley
the army of the Dead was eventually
gonna make it south of the wall but we
got a couple explainers so we know
what's up with Viserion now there was a
night king end game video that i did for
season 8 stuff like what is the actual
final battle it gonna look like how they
gonna defeat him how they gonna defeat
Viserion there were a lot of mechanical
questions about Viserion like how does
he work what are his powers is he still
able to fly so per this scene here it
looks like he has all the same abilities
that he had when he was still alive is
that now he breathes blew fire and for
those are you wondering whether or not
that makes sense i think the idea is
that the knight King's magic is just
preventing him from exploding into flame
because flame kills White's now that
he's an undead white if he breathed
flamed he should then also burst into
flames but it'll be a lot of fun to see
him flying around during season eight so
now he's super fast and I love the shot
of then just slowly casually walking
down through the wall like they just
roll up and stop they're not in a rush
at all but you see this giant black
winter storm behind that so when they
say the long night it literally looks
like night because the sky is so thick
with snow and storm that it blots out
all light so then you go back to the
shot of Circe's floor map with winter
falling on the kingdom and there's just
a lot of nice visual metaphors in the
episode so I was much happier with this
than almost any other episode this
season but let me know in the comments
favorite episode this season in favorite
moment in this episode but like I said
what's gonna happen next is I'll do my
season 8 predictions video then I'll do
my Q&A video you just leave all your
bonus video requests there's a bunch of
mythology things that we can talk about
now there haven't been any season 8
leaks so we can freely talk about
anything we want to now that the season
is over so it's all fair game
congratulations
the latest giveaway winner Andrew
Chamberlain please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to learn all about the Daenerys prophecy
me remaster and why she might have
another child and you can click here to
learn all about Rhaegar Liana back story
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight